en plateau à présent Didier bonob
bonsoir vous êtes organisateur de
parcours dans l'art actuel qui se
déroule du côté de Versailles et puis
Myriam rebou bonsoir à vous vous êtes
sortis vous participez à ce rendez-vous
rendez-vous qui permet de découvrir les
artistes le mot d'ordre de ce
rendez-vous qui fait déjà un ses 10 ans
c'est l'art partout dans la ville et
pour tous voilà c'est ça quel est le
principe un petit peu de parcours dans
l'art actuel le principe c'est comme les
ateliers portes ouvertes qu'on peut
trouver sur les arrondissements
parisiens ou dans d'autres villes en
France qui sont assez courants chaque
artiste en fait propose une rencontre
entre lui et le public dans son lieu de
création voilà donc ça ça permet de
créer un parcours dans tout Versailles
qui qui ouvre à peu près 54 lieux cette
année pour 86 artistes qui vont montrer
leur travail alors on voit quelques
images en situation justement voilà les
gens peuvent découvrir tout ça tout cela
est gratuit alors tout est gratuit bien
entendu et comme cette année nous fêtons
les dix ans de ce parcours dans l'heure
actuelle on a créé un concept justement
la répartie comme vous disiez c'est
exactement ça c'est de créer des
synergies avec 10 lieux dans Versailles
pour créer 10 expositions sur 10 thèmes
différents des expositions collectives
donc ou participent les artistes qui
participent au parcours dans l'heure
actuelle donc en plus des 53 à 4 de 54
ateliers il va y avoir 10 lieux qui
ouvrent leurs portes à des expositions
thématiques et collectives
de découvrir votre travail alors vous
travaillez sur le verre il sera possible
de découvrir votre travail ou à la
tangente donc un espace qui est ouvert à
plein d'autres artistes donc et qui
travaillent enfin qui travaillent sur le
thème de récup art donc la récupération
de l'art un rendez-vous particulier pour
pour les artistes justement ce moment
d'échange avec le public un petit peu
oui non seulement avec le public mais en
même temps entre les articles en fait
avec les autres artistes parce qu'en
fait ils ne se connaissent pas beaucoup
non plus donc ça permet d'échanger ça
permet de non c'est un bon lieu
d'échange et également avec la ville
parce que ça nous permet de d'ouvrir des
ateliers de se faire connaître plutôt
que d'être derrière ces murs parce que
c'est important pour un artiste de ce
artiste de se faire connaître parce que
souvent on a l'image de l'artiste qui
reste dans son atelier qui aime bien
travailler tranquillement absolument ça
c'est vrai forcément mais mais on a
besoin quand même d'une de savoir si ce
que l'on fait peut plaire éventuellement
autrement ça sert à rien une vraie
richesse justement de au niveau de la
création sur la ville de Versailles les
artistes sont nombreux ils sont nombreux
absolument
c'était aussi pour ça que vous avez créé
ce rendez-vous j'imagine pour parler
pour présenter cette richesse
versaillesse voilà bah initialement je
la connaissais pas trop la richesse mais
je pensais qu'elle existait quand même
et donc étant artiste j'ai voulu aller à
la rencontre des autres artistes de R5
dans mon cas et les faire sortir de leur
atelier justement pour se rencontrer
voici vous êtes artiste voici vous allez
présenter vos travaux on va en voir
quelques images vous pouvez nous
présenter peut-être un petit peu votre
travail donc quel domaine vous
intervenez moi je suis peintre donc mon
travail était un travail sur la réalité
et la fiction toujours le rapport
actuellement sur quelques images qui
passent sur le une peinture très très
abstraite très très chargée et des
petits des petits points très réalistes
qui viennent faire un contraste et qui
viennent justement voir la limite qui
peut y avoir entre cette fiction et
cette réalité
quoi parcours dans l'heure actuelle 10
au 28 octobre il y a des moments forts
également un point fort 20 21 octobre
c'est le parcours vraiment où les gens
peuvent se balader dans les dans tous
les ateliers de Versailles
quand on veut de 10 à 19h le 20-21 et on
revoit notamment vers le site de la
ville de Versailles où il y a toutes les
informations
à l'hôtel de ville aussi on peut avoir
le plan carrément et après faire son
propre parcours effectivement on peut
choisir ou non les artistes et
voilà à l'hôtel de ville il y a une
exposition où chaque artiste expose une
oeuvre donc les gens peuvent aller
d'abord dans cette exposition pour créer
leur propre parcours en fonction de leur
sensibilité quoi d'accord et ce
rendez-vous alors des 20 21 octobre 86
artistes 86 54 lieux oui qui présente
leurs travaux qui présente leurs travaux
chez eux dans leur lieu de création et
qu'on peut donc découvrir combien de de
nous avait dit d'artistes participent et
surtout est-ce que vous avez réussi à
fédérer tous les artistes il y en a qui
sont réticents quelquefois oui oui j'en
ai rencontré qui souhaite plutôt rester
seul
est-ce que vous avez été difficile à
convaincre non pas du tout parce que je
travaillais d'une façon très isolée ça
m'a permis au contraire de de
communiquer avec d'autres personnes
plutôt que d'être à l'intérieur de mes
murs donc je trouvais ça très
intéressant comme démarche vous y
participez depuis l'origine assurez-vous
depuis 8 ans
qui est que vous aimeriez faire venir
chaque année vous les RE solliciter
parce que là ça fait 10 ans maintenant
que le festival est aussi bien ancré le
parcours dans leur actuelle est bien
ancré ça peut peut-être faciliter les
demandes
c'est à dire que au début je sollicais
beaucoup maintenant en fait ils viennent
plutôt vers moi s'ils en ont envie quoi
et c'est vrai qu'on a de plus en plus de
candidatures et je découvre chaque année
des artistes de très bons niveaux qui
ont une aura nationale et qui en fait
habite où travaille sur Versailles qu'on
ne connaissait pas parcours dans l'art
actuel 10 au 28 octobre on vous invite à
vous y rendre peut-être ce weekend avec
la carte complète que vous pourrez
retrouver sur les différents sites
Internet de la Ville de Versailles merci
d'être venu sur notre plateau nous
parler de ce rendez-vous nous allons
conclure cette édition par un rappel des
titres très rapidement les sujets que
nous avons abordés ce soir elle les
travaux de rénovation à la gare de
Trappes prennent forme des travaux qui
se déroulent principalement de nuit en
ce moment vous avez vu comment
travailler ses ouvriers pendant votre
sommeil il est compliqué de trouver un
travail aujourd'hui c'est encore plus un
casse-tête quand on se trouve en
situation de handicap un forum était
organisé sur cette question et des
demandeurs d'emploi sont venus
directement à la rencontre des
recruteurs l'an passé 75 personnes ont
ainsi trouvé un travail la semaine du
goût c'est en ce moment un atelier était
proposé aujourd'hui vous le voyez à la
maison de quartier du Bois de l'étang à
La Verrière à destination des enfants un
diététicien est venu donner des conseils
pour une bonne alimentation et puis les
Fatals Picards seront en concert le
samedi 20 octobre à l'abri blues de
Bois-d'Arcy vous avez rencontré ce
groupe de rock parodique au cours de
notre page culture du mercredi ces
sujets sont aussi à retrouver sur notre
site Internet et puis dans l'actu toute
image de la rédaction 20h30 et 22h une
dernière information pour évoquer à
présent cette question du mariage
homosexuel après le maire du Chesnay
Philippe Briot qui a fait voter une
motion en conseil municipal contre le
projet de loi du mariage pour tous c'est
au tour d'un nouvel élu de droite de
prendre position Bernard de bain mère
UMP de Saint-Cyr-l'École il signait un
édito dans le dernier bulletin municipal
de la commune une lettre ouverte au
président de la République et il déclare
je vous informe mon refus de célébrer ce
que je ne peux approuver au nom dit-il
du droit de la liberté de conscience et
il ajoute ce projet va détruire ce qu'il
reste du mariage voilà pour cette
déclaration cette position du maire de
Saint-Cyr-l'École le 7 8 revient demain
en direct dès 18h au programme notamment
l'avenir de l'éolien passe-t-il par les
départements des Yvelines et puis le
duel Fillon Copé pour la tête de l'UMP
avec les réactions des élus locaux nous
reviendrons également sur la démission
puisque ça a été confirmé dans la
journée de Joël Regnault le maire de
plaisir qui va quitter son poste en
cours de mandat pour préparer les
élections de 2014 laisser la place sans
doute à son adjoint à la Culture nous en
parlerons plus de détails dans notre
édition de demain excellente soirée